I'll [ __ ] school you you a [ __ ] they
piss me off
[ __ ] you oh [ __ ] you Oh what happened if
we played one combat and then I beat you
at that Oh like that's gonna happen
what would you do you probably throw
yourself off a roof [ __ ] you
last week I had another meltdown where I
was just pissed for the whole episode
for good reason this is a good read me
yeah let me just find that out many good
reasons it's not gonna be better this
one I have a few of rants ready like a
like an old married couple and then you
get mad anybody get 100% uh-oh
how about bad a Mortal Kombat huh yeah
it's happening okay yeah whatever laughs
yeah oh we're doing it now [ __ ] oh
right now you think you're gonna stick
this one more when we gonna do a podcast
we gotta [ __ ] are gonna do right now
hot glass I got chicken out of here you
want to check the other out again is
that it okay
no that's fine all right yeah you're not
on world combat oh there you go yo [ __ ]
there yes oh look at that
Hey look behind the aint percent chance
of me winning how about that had two
percent chance of winning heck yes on
yet oh [ __ ] can you're gonna get [ __ ]
play oh I bet you been practicing this
you played you played a hundred little
magic and even touch this game all right
work that you've been playing so much
and like another account or Jesus what
button what button blocks I I will you
don't know that joint already I'm
connecting to the match we have crappy
internet and you're on skype with your
phone so spying I'm gonna work no it's
gonna work uh kind of [ __ ] Internet -
yeah man failed to connect the [ __ ] okay
you challenge me then
no just and I stared just just
disability because I'm trying to get out
of here oh you don't want to play no no
no go play okay why doesn't it joy
because we've joined each other's game
you know you could have done this
anytime this week you can chicken out
anytime no oh oh should I pick okay
I never I never played this you never
played ever ever played and ever did you
leave no I lost connection for [ __ ]
sake oh you got to get some of that
later we gotta get back this past